[Musik]
die stadt osterburg in sachsen-anhalt
nico schulz ist hier seit langem
bürgermeister für die freien wähler für
die villa in den landtag
in wenigen tagen wird gewählt vielen
gesprächen mit den bürgern hört man doch
nur große enttäuschung
gerade bei wlan die jetzt konservativ
ihren wollen in richtung cdu
und da sind natürlich die freien wähler
jetzt auch in einer zeit auf dem
politischen markt aktiv wo wir
tatsächlich eine gute option darstellen
schulz war zehn jahre lang für die cdu
im landtag vor zwei jahren verließ er
die partei
sie kümmere sich zu wenig um die leute
auf dem platten land schulz fordert 300
millionen euro mehr für die kommunen
natürlich bei den kommunalfinanzen
gerechter verteilen und da sagen wir
jeder bürger muss gleich behandelt
werden und damit auch die gemeinde
gleiche finanzielle zuweisungen bekommen
in sachsen-anhalt band ministerpräsident
reiner haseloff von der cdu um seine
macht auch wegen der freien wähler
nach der neuesten umfrage liegt die cdu
vor dem hauptkonkurrenten afd
die freien wähler mit drei prozent oder
mehr könnten der cdu entscheidende
stimme nehmen nach ganz rechts grenzen
sich die freien wähler scharf ab wir
haben im landesvorstand einen beschluss
gefasst dass wir falls wir den einzug in
den landtag schaffen nicht mit der ard
zusammenarbeiten und geschweige denn
koalieren werden trotzdem fordern die
freien wähler in ihrem
bundestagswahlprogramm zum beispiel ein
verbot der vollverschleierung und wollen
keine einwanderung in unsere sozialen
sicherungssysteme parteichef hubert
aiwanger hat mit dieser politik in
bayern über elf prozent geholt und macht
jetzt in sachsen-anhalt wahlkampf keine
einwanderung in unsere sozialen
sicherungssysteme slogan ist afd
sprechen
nein ich glaube dass die bürgerliche
mitte dieses thema in der verfehlten
zuwanderungspolitik besitzen muss um es
nicht der ofd zu überlassen
die häufiges auch deshalb so stark
geworden weil die parteien der mitte bei
diesen themen versorgt haben und eine
lücke aufgemacht haben im märz
2021 schafften die freien wähler in
mainz den einzug ins landesparlament mit
5,4 prozent
spitzenkandidat war joachim streit
[Musik]
der für streit historischen tag als
fraktionsvorsitzender beginnt mit der
ausgabe von dienstausweis und parkkarte
das büro noch fast leer
aber das wichtigste für ihn ist da ein
bild präsentiert mit etwas pathos das
sind die menschen für die wir einstehen
die braven leute die arbeiten den nicht
so schwer ist und da gibt es diese
versprechen die wichtig sind für deren
kinder das bildungs versprechen und für
sie selbst auch das wohlstands
versprechen
jetzt hofft er auf neue anhänger also
wir merken jetzt auch nachdem die cdu
laschet nominiert hat dass viele cdu
mitglieder zu uns wechseln möchten
streits landtagsfraktion ist so stark
wie die fdp
jahrzehntelange kommunalpolitische
arbeit zahlt sich nun aus
landkreis bitburg-prüm hier machtstreit
seit 27 jahren für die freien wähler
politik bürgermeister landrat und jetzt
fraktionschef im landtag trotz 5,4
prozent freund streit von den freien
wählern als volkspartei volkspartei ist
für mich das thema alle kommen mit
ob das nun 15 oder 20 prozent später
sein werden das weiß ich nicht aber für
mich ist wichtig wir haben das breite
spektrum offen streitmacht womit jetzt
auch die cdu punkten will mehr
klimapolitik regionale versorgung mit
erneuerbaren energien in der eifel
dort wo die cdu einst über 70 prozent
holte
früher hat man gesagt in der eifel
kannst du einen besenstiel auf stellen
schreibt cdu drauf und er wird gewählt
stammwählerschaft einbrechen aber weg im
vordergrund stehen kandidaten und die
inhalte die sie vertreten
nach dem erfolg in rheinland-pfalz sehen
die freien wähler jetzt erstmals chancen
im bund vier monate vor der
bundestagswahl stehen sie
deutschlandweit bei drei prozent wenn
die umfragen so bleiben dann werden die
freien wähler ein entscheidender faktor
bei dieser wahl seien gerade deshalb
weil die anderen parteien 26 turm
bewegen und das rennen zwischen grünen
und cdu extrem knapp ausgehen wird
wiesbaden wie sehr die union die freien
wähler fürchtet zeigte sich schon 2006
in hessen vor einer landtagswahl
michael krönung und die freien wähler
hatten damals einen erfolgreichen
kommunalwahlkampf hinter sich holten zum
entsetzen der cdu landesweit mehr als
fünf prozent und das natürlich so die
magische grenze wo man sich überlegen
muss wächst dort eine neue politische
kraft im tor und wie gefährlich kann die
einem werden und das wurde anscheinend
so bewertet dass wir entsprechend auch
stimmen wegnehmen können und dass wir
entsprechend dazu auch geeignet sind und
den landtag einzuziehen
der damalige cdu-ministerpräsident
roland koch wollte verhindern dass die
freien wähler zur landtagswahl 2008
antreten
koch lockte mit geld versprach ein
gesetz zur kostenerstattung bei
kommunalwahlen
es wurde also klar gesagt dieses gesetz
kommt nur tritt nur in kraft wenn ihr
euch vorher entscheidet nicht zu einer
landtagswahl anzutreten und das haben
wir natürlich entschieden abgelehnt wir
waren doch die freien wähler
kandidierten zur landtagswahl roland
koch wir kommen doch plakatierten sie
und erreichten damals doch nur 0,9
prozent 15 jahre später im fränkischen
forchheim sind die freien wähler
zweitstärkste partei thorsten glauber
holte bei drei landtagswahlen in folge
mehr als 20 von 29 bürgermeistern im
landkreis stellen wir zehn und aktuell
die csu neun und damit sind wir
natürlich schon auch eine klare kraft
hier und diese vernetzung in denen die
kommunen funktioniert und damit auch
natürlich auch sowohl im kreistag und
wirken damit auch in die landespolitik
schon sein vater reinhard war
jahrzehntelang kommunalpolitiker der
freien wähler zuletzt landrat später
kandidierten vater und sohn gemeinsame
wahlplakate heute ist thorsten glauber
bayerischer umweltminister im kabinett
von markus söder den koalitionspartner
csu treibt glaube vor sich her
mit seinem klimaschutzgesetz
im entwurf heißt es spätestens im jahr
2040 soll bayern klimaneutral sein fünf
jahre früher als im bund wir müssen dem
klimawandel trotzen und das machen wir
mit letztendlich unsere politik
in sachsen anhalt wird am sonntag
gewählt es ist die erste landtagswahl
seitdem armin laschet kanzlerkandidat
der union ist die hat nun noch mehr
konkurrenz durch die freien wähler
natürlich ist da jede stimme die nicht
an die cdu geht sondern eine freie
wähler für armin laschet ein sehr großes
ärgernis weil es am ende sehr eng werden
wird wir wollen der cdu/csu feuer unterm
hintern machen und es wäre der falsche
weg zu sagen wir bleiben zu hause damit
lasse trotz eines schwachen auftritts in
europa stimmen mehr bekommt wir nehmen
wohl nicht nur dem laschet stimmen weg
sondern auch den andern